[Musique]
les derniers sondages sont unanimes il
existe bien une dynamique autour de la
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
de valérie pécresse la présidence de la
région ile-de-france la candidate
soutenue par les républicains élus d y
seraient autour des 16 % d'intentions de
vote au premier tour de quoi lui assurer
une qualification face à emmanuel macron
alexandra dublanche bonjour et bienvenue
en plateau vous êtes la vice-présidente
de la région ile-de-france
maire-adjointe de sartrouville porte
parole aussi de valérie pécresse cette
place justement qu'occupe aujourd'hui
valérie pécresse dans les sondages elle
le doit peut-être aussi à la division du
vote de l'extrême droite avec les deux
candidatures eric zemmour et et marine
le pen est ce que ça vous amène à
relativiser aussi les chiffres de votre
candidate ces sondages je pense qu'il
manque surtout une envie d'alternance de
la part des français entre l'immobilisme
des manuels macron et la démagogie de
l'extrême droite et donc ils ont ils se
sont manifestés et maintenant il ya une
adhésion des français pour un projet le
projet de valérie pécresse et la droite
et le centre ont enfin leur candidat je
pense qu'il y avait une espèce
d'expectative en attendant que la droite
et enfin son candidat et maintenant la
droite et le centre vont faire bloc
après il faut rester il faut savoir
raison garder non il n'ya pas du tout de
triomphalisme de notre part ça va être
une campagne longue une campagne intense
il va falloir que valérie pécresse à
convaincre chaque français de la valeur
de son programme et des solutions
qu'elle apporte aux problèmes des
français vous parler de cette union de
la droite et du centre derrière sa
candidate désignée l'enjeu c'est de
maintenir cette entente aussi et quitte
à faire quelquefois peut-être un grand
écart aussi dans les propositions entre
eric ciotti et valérie pécresse je ne
pense pas qu'il y ait grand écart la
droite et diverses nous le savons chacun
exprimé ses sensibilités pendant une
primaire qui s'est extrêmement bien
déroulé qui je pense a donné une très
belle image de la droite en termes de
fonds et de solidité des solutions que
les candidats à portet et valérie
pécresse a le projet qui a été
choisi par donc ses adhérents des
républicains et bien sûr elle doit
maintenant s'efforcer de rassembler
toutes ses sensibilités mais elle a déjà
un programme très fort sur le régalien
sur l'ordre sur l'autorité et comme mal
à expliquer maintenant il s'agit d'aller
reprendre quelques idées des autres pour
agrémenter le projet mais le projet dans
ses grandes lignes var est exactement le
même puisqu'il a été choisi fait une
petite petite aparté pour parler du
département des yvelines certains dans
les yvelines ont quitté la droite pour
emmanuel macron je pense au maire de
poissy au maire de saint germain en laye
vous leur dites quoi qu'il devrait
peut-être y réfléchir à deux fois et
revenir dans le giron des républicains
peut-être passé des personnes qui ont
soutenu massivement valérie pécresse aux
dernières régionales moi toute façon on
va s'adresser à tout le monde et à
toutes les personnes en montrant que
encore une fois nos solutions sont les
plus efficaces pour répondre aux
problématiques
d'immigration de sécurité
de changement climatique d'emploi
d'éducation et donc on va aller
convaincre tout le monde et que ceux qui
veulent nous rejoindre ils sont
évidemment tous les biens de ceux qui
sont partis sont les bienvenus pour
revenir sur bien sûr valérie pécresse si
on reste sur l'échelon local justement
est toujours la présidente de la région
de l'île de france comment va se passer
cette campagne pour ce mandat il faut
aussi poser sur président de la
république qu'il arrive il a fait
remarquer qu'il a eu à faire les deux
aussi et donc il n'y a aucun sujet je
rappelle que on a voté 80% du projet de
qu'on a présenté aux franciliens pour
les élections régionales avant l'été on
est tous en train de le mettre en oeuvre
moi je suis en train de mettre en oeuvre
dans le cadre du développement
économique on est évidemment on
abandonne absolument pas la région et on
continue en non les deux de front sk des
déclinaisons justement des propositions
qui ont été faites et des actions qui
sont menées à la région sur le programme
pour la présidentielle même si on ne
gouverne pas de la même manière un pays
une région je pense que la baisse des
dépenses publiques
c'est un très bel exemple valérie
pécresse a réussi en cinq ans a baissé
les dépenses publiques en ile de france
2 2 milliards d'euros on a réduit les
effectifs de la région on a supprimé des
organismes qui ne brillait pas par leur
efficacité donc on a montré qu'avec une
politique courageuse on était capable de
diminuer ses dépenses de fonctionnement
pour investir ailleurs investir dans les
lycées investir dans les transports et
donc c'est aussi un projet qu'elle porte
au niveau national en ayant cet exemple
cette espèce d'expérimentation
francilienne ou allah elle a prouvé
qu'elle pouvait le faire et maintenant
faut le faire au niveau de la france on
va parler un peu plus des propositions
juste avant un mot sur votre candidature
aussi puisque vous avez été désignée
candidate dans la 5e circonscription
pour récupérer d'ailleurs cette 5ème
circonscription parce qu'elle a été
gagnée en 2017 par yale bonne pub et
pour la majorité présidentielle
vous êtes donc candidate c'est une
candidature de reconquête
c'est une candidature où je vais porter
aussi ce projet pour la france 2 valérie
pécresse et dans un territoire auquel je
suis très attaché puisque j'ai vu mes
enfants ils sont nés j'y suis
effectivement adjointe au maire de
sartrouville j'ai le soutien des maires
de sartrouville de montesson du
mesnil-le-roi et de nombreux élus et je
remercie d'ailleurs ma famille politique
m'a investi à l'unanimité sur cette
circonscription de gérard larcher à
christian jacob avec ce tee et c'est
donc il compte sur moi pour
effectivement reconquérir cette
circonscription et que je mets toute mon
énergie et mes compétences je pense au
service maintenant de ce territoire au
niveau national même si l'élection
législative a lieu après la
présidentielle et qui a toujours une
dynamique présidentielle donc on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler bien sûr une
fois que les choses sont un petit peu
plus clair forcément par la suite
parlons des propositions pour l'instant
de votre candidate valérie pécresse
retraite à 65 ans en 2030 fin des 35
heures est ce qu'il va falloir
travailler plus pour gagner plus jetons
reprendre un slogan de l'utiliser
valérie pécresse elle tient un discours
de vérité
la réforme des emmanuel macron cetc
annoncé dès le début de son mandat comme
un grand réformateur or on voit bien
qu'il ya des grandes réformes qui n'a
absolument pas fait je pense en premier
lieu à la réforme des retraites je pense
à la décentralisation mais ça c'est
plutôt lié à son mode de gouvernement
qu'ils ne quitteraient verticale et qui
ne veut pas s'appuyer pas assez sur les
territoires et donc effectivement nous
allons devoir faire des réformes
courageuses pour pouvoir encore une fois
relevé le pays tous les pays européens
autour de nous sont haut à minima à 65
ans donc oui quand on vit beaucoup plus
longtemps il va falloir vivre plus mais
il y aura aussi une politique sociale
très importante pour ceux qui ont
commencé très tôt par exemple à
travailler et aussi avec une petite son
pouvoir d'achat d'augmentation des
salaires nets pour que le travail paye
plus que l'assistanat pour bruno le
maire ancien républicain est lui aussi
aujourd'hui ministre des manuels macron
les premières propositions de votre
candidat de son jeu site du recyclage il
dit que le projet le frappe c'est un
projet de recyclage un projet pour le
vingtième siècle et pas pour le 21e
siècle
écoutez moi je vois là ce genre moi je
me souviens de bruno le maire en plein
milieu de l'organigramme de françois
fillon de campagne voilà c'est des gens
et qui se targue d'avoir fait une
politique forte or économique certes sur
les entreprises le soutien pendant la
crise mais irresponsable en termes de
dette et de déficit public et donc c'est
pas du recyclage c'est juste que ça n'a
pas été fait donc maintenant il faut le
faire et c'est ce que propose valérie
pécresse c'est d'enfin faire ces
réformes que tout le monde a promises et
que qui n'ont pas été faits dans les
quintés n'a de françois hollande et
d'emmanuel macro sea forcément on se
présente à l'élection présidentielle
c'est pour aborder la réalité de la
fonction mais il ya aussi toujours un
moment où il faut faire rêver adhérer
autour de son projet aujourd'hui vous
dites quoi aux électeurs vous dites bien
sûr il faut faire rêver et vous donner
de l'espoir mais la situation économique
notamment sera compliqué pour le
quinquennat qui suivra avec la situation
de la crise sanitaire forcément qui n'a
pas aidé c'est vraiment il ya des
projets
c'est un projet d'avenir aussi c'est un
projet qui fait face à l'urgence
climatique c'est un projet qui propose
de refonder l'école pour que chaque
enfant de france et ses chances ce n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui et c'est un
projet responsable moi voilà c'est
vraiment aussi ce que je retiens c'est
un projet qui va ne va pas hypothétique
et hypothéquer l'avenir de nos enfants
en s'endettant avec des chèques en blanc
sans cesse vraiment c'est un progrès
sérieux budgétés et qui propose un
meilleur avenir à tous qui est aussi un
projet qui va vers plus d'autorité de
l'état on constate depuis plusieurs
années une impuissance totale de l'état
en termes de sécurité de faire face à
une immigration incontrôlée et donc
c'est un projet pour que chaque français
puisse vivre mieux demain bien
évidemment même si une période un peu
compliquée avec la situation économique
mais il ya vous prédire l'avenir mais il
faudra reconstruire aussi bien c'est de
toute façon puis d'ailleurs on l'a
montré à je reviens à la région ile de
france on a su être au rendez vous parce
que on avait aussi fait des économies
avant de l'adie des difficultés
économiques de nos commerçants de nos
restaurateurs on a été très présent on a
même aidé l'état sur l'aspect sanitaire
avec les masques les tests etc donc on a
été très présent et on saura l'aide dans
une période compliquée ou plus positif
sur l'immigration justement le projet
c'est de mettre en place des quotas
d'accueil par métier aussi par pays à
travers une loi constitutionnelle oui la
différence je pense de valérie pécresse
aussi par cette primaire c'est qu'elle
est jusqu'au fond des choses il ya
beaucoup d'intentions d'ailleurs on
entend aussi de l'extrême droite
beaucoup bon le diagnostic je pense
quand le partage à peu près tous après
c'est l'action la politique c'est cette
en mesure de faire est de mettre en
oeuvre parce que tout le monde est
capable de faire un discours et ce avec
valérie pécresse est allé au fond des
choses avec ce projet de loi
constitutionnelle donc oui les quotas
migratoires qui avait été aussi proposé
lors de la dernière présidentielle et qu
on a évidemment pas pu mettre en oeuvre
puisqu'on n'a pas été élu il faut le
faire maintenant puisqu'on et on voit
bien toutes les problématiques on est
incapable d'accueillir toute la misère
du monde pour reprendre une expression
il faut être davantage sélectif pour
mieux aussi accueillir les gens et avoir
moins
d'implication sociale de l'immigration
est-ce qu'on va assister pendant cette
campagne une surenchère des propositions
sur ces questions là avec les
candidatures à l'extrême droite
notamment est ce que la droite va garder
son cap ou est-ce qu'il va y avoir un
voit la proposition une course à
l'échalote malheureuse sur ce sujet je
ne pense pas s'il s'agit pas d'aller de
toujours plus à droite c'est pas ça
c'est de répondre aux inquiétudes des
français qui sont réelles et le faire
avec des solutions crédibles ce qui
n'est absolument pas le cas de l'extrême
droite et je pense que c'est ce qui nous
distingue c'est peut-être aussi ce qui
est en train d'expliquer un peu les
tendances des sondages on se rend compte
que la droite partagent un diagnostic
mais apporte des solutions concrètes et
réalistes contrairement à l'extrême
droite on vient de célébrer le 116e
anniversaire de la séparation de
l'église et de l'état la laïcité qui est
aujourd'hui mise à mal ça c'est une
réalité juste revenir sur quelques
chiffres et sur un chiffre notamment 40%
des lycéens je rappelle que les lycées
c'est une des compétences de la région
40 % des lycéens estiment que les normes
et les règles de leur religion sont plus
importantes que les lois de la
république c'est un chiffre qui vous
inquiète c'est terrible ce lycéen sur
deux qui est sa religion doit primer sur
les lois de la république c'est terrible
et on essaye d'agir énormément alors là
c est lycéen au niveau de nationale bien
sûr on essaie au niveau de la région je
vous rappelle on était la première
région première collectivité même de
france a lancé une charte de la laïcité
pour qu'il n'y ait pas un euro d'argent
public
qu'ils aillent à des associations qui
prônent des valeurs contre la république
donc on agit beaucoup en forme tous nos
cadres sportifs donc c'est un travail
minutieux qu'il faut faire pas à pas
c'est ce qu'on a fait c'est ce qu'on
veut faire évidemment au niveau du pays
d'ailleurs l'état s'est inspiré de nous
puisqu'ils ont repris après cette charte
de la laïcité par exemple on sent qu'il
ya un travail à faire auprès des plus
jeunes générations aussi
très tôt et donc il faut avoir aussi un
discours fort un discours d'amour de la
france ne pas expliquer qu'il n'y a pas
de culture française par exemple comme
l'avait fait le président de la
république et donc c'est un travail très
transversal que valérie pecresse amène à
mener dans sa région et qu'elle mènera
au niveau national nous reste quelques
instants pour conclure cet entretien
l'élaboration du programme va se
poursuivre et j'imagine jusqu'au début
vraiment de la pleine campagne dans les
dernières lignes droites comment va se
passer cette élaboration des rencontres
avec les françaises et les français
malgré la situation sanitaire compliquée
et qui rend compliqué la tenue ne serait
ce que dans meetings valérie pécresse va
continuer à se déplacer dans le respect
des contraintes sanitaires bien
évidemment cette semaine elle a été
auprès d'eric ciotti
aux alentours de nice auprès de philippe
juvin aujourd'hui elle est à lille avec
xavier bertrand donc elle continue à
aller à la rencontre des français sur
les thématiques qui leur sont chers et
bien sûr qu'elle va continuer à enrichir
ce projet on va rentrer encore davantage
dans le détail même si la structure et
les grandes propositions resteront
identiques et ne changeront pas merci
beaucoup alexandra du banc-vert parole
de valérie pécresse candidate donc à
l'élection présidentielle c'est la fin
de cet entretien politique on se
retrouve bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]